[Music]  the Kardashian family is rallying around  Khloe amid reports Tristan Thompson  allegedly stepped out with other women  as they prepare to welcome their first  child together a source tells ET quote  Kris has gathered the family and made  sure they would all be there for her  they are so excited for Khloe her  sisters are being super supportive  despite any photos or video of Tristan  with other women our source says they  want Khloe to focus on the only thing  that matters right now  her daughter quote they won't let any  news change the importance of how  beautiful this birth is for Khloe as for  Tristan the Kardashians really like him  the source said they want nothing more  than to believe he's a stand-up guy and  that this was all a setup